okay so thor 11 thunder is packed with a
lot of big moments a major ending and
mention of a thorgy that will hopefully
get on the deleted scenes when the movie
releases on disney plus fingers crossed
but either way there's a lot of
questions that you probably have about
the film so i thought i'd break down the
ones that i've seen asked the most on my
recent ending explain video this
includes how goal lifted storm breaker
how love works and what jane said to
thor at the end so make sure you stick
around because of this though there will
be major spoilers so if you haven't
checked it out then check out now if you
enjoy the video then please hit the
thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this every
day by the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into thor love and
thunder
now the big question i see being axed is
how did gord the god butcher manage to
lift stormbreaker it's something that's
often brought up on videos whenever a
character like thanos grabs the axe but
it's actually very straightforward the
main confusion of this comes from people
having to be worthy in order to lift
malnuar minie mumu
jonathan so in the first thor movie when
we open the film every single character
could have lifted that hammer that's
right even you you loser it was only
upon thor fighting the frost giants that
odin put the spell on it which meant
that only those that were worthy could
pick it up so the only reason people
can't lift the hammer is because of the
spell that was placed on it by odin at
the start of the first thor movie now on
the opposite side of this the spell was
never added to stormbreaker when it was
forged by etree the dwarf group branched
out and gave his arm so that it had a
handle however at no point did anyone
say anything like only those who like
and subscribe can lift this this is why
thanos can use it in avengers end game
and it's also why gore is able to carry
it as well on top of this love can carry
a two and not needing to prove that
she's worthy is one of the reasons that
she takes the axe whilst he takes moon
moon here now though she draws on it we
see that this is when it's rested up in
a bed so yeah didn't even need to lift
it hopefully that explains it mate and
you can stop asking 500 times in a video
cause i've explained it to you just
remember anyway we see the piece i love
your we see the pieces of the hammer on
display at one point in the film when
jane thunder visits new asgard jody
arrives there to catch you in a glass
case and i've seen a lot of people that
are made up for this video wondering how
the pieces were moved well if you look
around it you can actually see that
blades of grass surround it these are
likely well i know they are these are
the same blades of grass that surrounded
it when it was destroyed by heller all
the way back in thor ragnarok now in
order to display it like this all
they've done is excavate the site and
dug around where it was last seen you
can even tell this by the rock in the
background that odin died at it's a big
thing people need explaining to them and
i might have even pulled the video last
time because even i got it wrong and had
to have it explained to me in the
comments which i appreciate now in order
to display it the asgardians would have
dug up this land and just placed the
glass bowl around the top of it ammonia
very much plays upon the idea of
newton's first law of motion this states
that an object will remain in place if
no net force is exerted on it the reason
it sticks to the ground is because
gravity is pushing it down in place
however the earth is also pushing up and
therefore it remains stationary this is
also why people can grab it whilst it's
moving through the air like we saw with
spider-man in avengers endgame the
hammer is classed as being electrostatic
and therefore it just remains in place
unable to be moved now the hammer brings
with it the powers of a god for jane
foster the main reason that it protects
jane is because though put a spell on it
similar to how odin did that means it
will always watch out for her though she
initially thinks that this will improve
her health we actually discover that
it's killing her but paul you say surely
this makes no sense well listen you
idiot here's how it works so gods are
pretty much indestructible beings that
border on being immortals they have
lifespans that last for thousands and
thousands of years and with this comes
hardened cells and an almost
indestructible immune system though
isn't the type of person that would get
a cold because his body would just wipe
out the virus as soon as it entered his
system now in the case of jane this also
counts for her chemotherapy drugs as
soon as she changes into the mighty thor
her cells are hardened her immune system
is strengthened and this instantly wipes
out all the drugs in her system however
this power also hardens the cancer cells
and it strengthens them so they
themselves become superpowered therefore
they attack the rest of her cells at an
accelerated speed and kill her even
quicker than she would have died without
the treatment throughout the film we
follow her as she works with thor he
takes stormbreaker and she takes magnet
there's also some jealousy amongst the
weapons too and you could say they're in
a polyhammorous relationship
shout out to idk for that one and
throughout the film we discover that
gore is traveling to eternity thor
travels back home and then he's able to
immediately fly there through using
zeus's thunderbolt now this has been
confusing a lot of people as it took
them a long time to travel to the shadow
realm in order to go toe-to-toe with
gore however thor went back there in a
split second using the thunderbolt but
firstly this is because the entrance to
eternity can really be created anywhere
this is why we see it forming around the
children and gore before he arrives at
it it just so happened to be that they
were in the shadow realm when it was
summoned it can really be anywhere in
the entire universe which we'll talk
more about in just a bit now on top of
this the thunderbolt is the tool of the
god of gods aka zeus it's likely that
he's omnipotent because he's able to
travel out well throughout using the
lightning bolt therefore thor having
this also means he can appear anywhere
at once he also has a link to
stormbreaker which is how he can call it
using his hand so thor knew where
eternity was because of it and he could
teleport there which is why the circle
of lightning appears around him just
before he vanishes next question what
the f is that well that takes us into
our bed about eternity and love eternity
is very much an embodiment of the entire
universe and in the comics everything
and everyone existed within him he's
very much the universe as much as the
universe is him and he encompasses all
existence eternity can also control
everything within the universe such as
time life death magic and both light and
dark matter this is how he is able to
grant any wish and bring love back
although it was pretty stupid asking for
this though cause everyone knows you get
one wish you wish for a million wishes
you damn punk what an
idiot
oh what a loser
now at this point love is brought forth
and she appears in the reflection of the
water looking much like eternity she is
very much an offshoot of him that
encompasses the original love's thoughts
memories consciousness and everything
about her from him however she's also
very much a being of eternity and that's
why she also has some of his abilities
at the end it is possible that she will
end up being classed as one of the
children of eternity who aren't to be
confused with the children of eternity
that were blight villains these were a
bunch of kid vampires whereas the actual
kids of eternity ended up becoming
concepts such as empathy entropy
epiphany and so on i actually think that
love will become the concept love and
that she will provide this with all in
their father and daughter relationship
now it's not really like eternity to
grant wishes and in the comics i can't
even think of a major time that this has
been done most of the time he's watching
over everything with characters like the
living tribunal and his sister infinity
just sitting back chilling now both of
these appear in the statue room that
leads to him and i think that down the
line we will see more of these
characters popping up in the mcu okay on
the end of the film we see that jane is
taken to valhalla after her death she
doesn't technically die in battle but
maybe eternity is outside of time and
space
so it doesn't moving on now what i've
seen asked quite a lot is how the
afterlifes in the mcu are connected so
far we've had one in black panther moon
knight had its own one and now we also
have valhalla they're all different so
how can they all exist as the afterlife
well let's take it to moonlight where
tarouwod explains it
this is the afterlife the afterlife and
afterlife not the
afterlife
you'd be surprised how many
intersectional planes of untethered
consciousness exist and because the jew
arts true nature is impossible for the
human mind to comprehend right you may
perceive this realm as something more
easily recognizable to you bit
hypocritical hate to have so many that
doesn't really work but basically what
it means is that the afterlife is
whatever you associate with the most
moonite aligns with the egyptian view of
death so he goes to that i'm not sure
how reincarnation works but whatever you
associate your faith or belief with is
what will happen to you now this could
also explain how jane doesn't die in
battle but she still gets there maybe
the battle thing was an interpretation
by the living of how to get into
valhalla and this could show that she
gets to go there anyway now lastly i
want to talk about what jane's
catchphrase is throughout the movie she
comes up with several but never drops
hammer time which would have been a good
one however i've went back and have
watched the film with the volume boosted
thanks to my good mate who works at
slotlight and i can now officially
reveal what it is so when jane leans in
she pulls him close and says see